[Music]
I'm gonna go through some history how
storage' Spotify looked like in the past
years then San is gonna continue with
some details about cloud BigTable then
I'm gonna go through the migration
process that we are doing at Spotify and
then I'm going to add some details about
the BigTable autoscale app that we built
during this process so some history so
when I join Spotify was three years two
years ago three years and a half ago and
we just started moving to GCP I remember
and I've been exposed marginally to what
was there before
that was basically on-prem data centers
we had four of them two in the US and
two in Europe and so we used to manage
our machines and beam in the storage
infrastructure team at the time and
still em we had basically two data base
so it looked like yes like we had
Cassandra and Postgres so that means
that we also manage our data base not
just the machines so in this talk I'm
gonna focus quite a lot on Cassandra
because it became extremely popular
Spotify and I'm gonna start telling you
why it became so popular in in a word
her son is versatile so it can do many
things quite well
it has tunable consistency it has
tunable performance he has a lot of
knobs that you can tune to almost
optimize the use case level I would say
has global implication it scales pretty
well from very small like order of
megabytes two terabytes in terms of data
set asides and it comes with a handy
query language similar to sequel and
like Twitter instructions so you can
express things like insert if not exist
which is a pretty powerful feature
this Fisher made like a standard did a
device fortify as I said and here are
some numbers that I digged took me quite
a while to find that because from like
when Kasana was at peak there was
approximately one one year one year and
a half ago yeah so we have a lot of
machines flower clusters and in that but
Cassandra yeah even if it was widely
used is not perfect it comes with a set
of promise I would say the biggest is
the fact that storage is copies couple
to compute and this makes topology
changes very expensive because I think
like for example we are running out of
disk and you are forced to scale out
your your cluster even if maybe you
don't need more compute for example and
topology changes needs to shuffled it
around so it takes a lot of time like
especially if you have a lot of data as
I said is very tunable which is good but
it's also bad sometimes because it's too
much he has a very long learning curve
and means like teams needs to be her
experts at operating Cassandra and in
our case we manage some of these
clusters the most critical ones but in
general we have the we believe in the so
called opsin squad so the the the teams
manage their their own clusters so yeah
it comes with a pretty high operational
burden in that sense it scales until it
doesn't
pretty much we had some cases where we
like we really felt like we we couldn't
add any more nodes to a specific cluster
we really would blow up and the
Cassandra person we use which is not
data stacks doesn't come with defects
percent backups so also that was
freaking in my theme we used to build
tools basically to alleviate these pains
so we provide automation to other
in the company and all sort of things
today we already mentioned like for
example we have tools for just
configuration and like you know they
thing and topology changes one of them
is sea star that we open source is
basically a power parallel SSH topology
aware so it knows for example if you
want to restore Cassandra knows in which
order you should do it to not to avoid
having unavailable data unavailable
ranges of data we have
Cassandra River that means it maybe is
the most famous tool we wrote is about
anti interfere pairs we wrote tools for
data exports the heads or and Hecuba is
for topology changes like also things
and we eventually got to a pretty good
spot like say pretty much give me a
Cassandra cluster with these number of
nodes with this machine type with
backups in exports on a schedule and
yeah
so pretty much quite easy but there's a
lot of work in maintaining all these
tools and some operations are still
extremely expensive like imagine you
want to update the operating system on
three four thousand hosts it takes a
long time
in this setting we started looking at
cloud providers and we eventually chose
GCP it not only because of storage but I
mean the mood to disappear was framing a
much bigger scope of course but and the
idea was to basically move up the stack
in a sense so free as much as possible
our time and do things more closely
related to other business logic instead
of doing infrastructure and managing
machines it should be cheaper also and
yeah that was basically the idea and we
should also it should also be possible
to so having more time and working a
different abstraction level to add value
on top of these technologies and we have
many success stories of this like CEO
for scheduling
jobs in all sort of jobs I guess not
sorry sticks is for scheduling and Co is
for dinner for jobs for Saffy security
and and the autoscaler there I'm gonna
talk about later I would say we mostly
succeeded in achieving these things and
now we're fully anticipate but even if
you're full anticipate the situation
look like this for for a while more so
basically we just migrated the physical
machines to VMs and were fairly well but
at some point we ask yourself I can we
use something that Google is providing
like managed storage very BigTable
public till and Sandy's gonna continue
talking about that thanks Millie oh yeah
I just want to provide a brief overview
of cloud BigTable and where we think it
delivers customers value like Spotify so
really quickly what is cloud BigTable
cloud BigTable is a petabyte scale fully
managed no sequel database the original
BigTable technology was built to index
the web and in its history has served
billion user applications within Google
like Gmail and search the cloud product
is meant to serve use cases where low
latency data access scalability and
reliability are critical as a fully
managed service at scales seamlessly and
we're also well integrated with the
appacha ecosystem offering an HBase API
on BigTable sits within a broader
portfolio of database and storage
products all of which remove the burden
of building and managing storage and
infrastructure specifically it sits in
the non relational space as a wide
column store again offering super high
performance in terms of latency and
throughput so what can cloud BigTable
offer you where does the value come from
I tend to focus on four areas speed
scalability full management and
integrations I'll talk about speed and
scalability more in a second because I
think that's what's differentiating
about
table and integration is with a broader
ecosystem is what allows it to plug
easily into your existing architecture
but I want to pause for a second on full
management because this is something
we're thinking about very holistically
what is it what can we do to lessen the
operational cost of managing a database
and so some of that yes is managing the
infrastructure and database layer having
our sres page so that you're not paged
it also means delivering the
availability data durability and
security that you've come to expect from
Google but for me it also means
providing value add tools to make the
database easier to work with in every
way so one quick example of that is key
visualizer which we launched last year
at next which is basically a heat map of
your key space and shows data access
patterns so again not only are we
managing that infrastructure and keeping
you from getting paged we're also giving
you visibility into your data and making
the parts of the process that you own
like schema design a lot easier so again
as a managed service we're thinking a
lot about how to reduce that operational
burden and as promised jumping into
speed again this is where I think
BigTable is unique on the throughput
side we're offering 10 megabytes per
second and write throughput and 220
megabytes per second and read scan
throughput I want to emphasize here that
generally in BigTable reads and writes
are the same price so customers with
write heavy workloads in particular will
see excised performance because of that
high write throughput and we also offer
low latency random data access in the
single-digit milliseconds scalability so
I think there are two things to focus on
here again BigTable was built for scale
and has the ability to handle internet
sized applications
that's because performance which you
measure in QPS queries per second scales
linearly as you increase the number of
nodes
I think our published guidelines say
that you should expect 10,000 QPS per
and that's true whether you have three
notes or 300 and second you can scale up
and scale down with big tables super
easily again this is what makes big
table price effective for spiky
workloads because you can scale up to
handle the spike and back down when
things cool down and amelia is gonna
speak a little bit about how they
leverage this characteristic in building
their autoscaler to get cost savings but
to dive a little bit deeper on how big
table is able to deliver that price or
that performance and scale I want to
touch a little bit on how big table
works so big table separates the
processing layer from the storage layer
which allows us to optimize throughput
by adjusting the association of storage
and nodes so in this example we start
with three nodes and four splits of the
data that are stored separately in our
storage layer and in the rebalancing
example we might be seeing heavy traffic
to data group a and so node 1 is
experiencing large load in this case big
table is going to automatically
rebalance and move some of that traffic
to another load ensuring broader a
better overall performance and again
resizing comes into a play when another
node is added to the mix and again we're
able to rebalance without any downtime
because instead of moving data around
we're just reassigning the node to a
different data group I also wanted to
touch base on one feature that's been
recently made available and that Spotify
has leveraged pretty intensely which is
a cloud BigTable replication replication
is allows you to increase your
availability with a 99.99% SLA by
allowing you to failover in the case of
a geo disaster it also allows you to
isolate batch and serving workloads and
finally if you're replicating globally
like Spotify does you can serve a global
user base
I'm making by offering customers low
latency data access to local replicas
there are a few things that I think are
special here you write data once and you
can write data to any one of those
replicas and it's automatically
replicated everywhere with zero
consistency and finally there are no
manual steps so you're not writing tools
to repair data or synchronize writes and
deletes replication just works and will
eventually be consistent um we have a if
you're interested in learning more about
replication my hope you'll join Carter
page our engineering manager and talking
about it tomorrow
that is DBS 307 at 2:10 p.m. building a
global data presence that's my quick
plug yeah
handing it back over to Emilio to talk
about how they approached the migration
thank you so yeah how our migration well
yeah first let's that just a short recap
about what Stanley said like the club
table is managed is eventually
consistent like a sander but no electric
transactions storage is decouple from
compute and is designed for big data
sets so the first thing you might ask
yourself is are Cassandra the same thing
as BigTable and yeah the answer is most
of the time you can map data sets that
you had on Cassandra to a big table we
found a Spotify that the most common
scenarios that we can map very well are
eventually consists of low consistency
will needs when we have ephemeral
similar system data maybe you have
regionally partitioned data and by this
I mean that certain set of the data is
accessed only from certain region like
for example European data is on access
in Europe and so on because they have
some cool features are available in the
way and the single row transactions
basically and of course large this sets
this use case map
very well other use cases they don't
math well we found some we found that we
had as you can imagine some cases where
you use this insert if not exist and
this is not the Olympic table so it
simply simply you simply have to find
something else and also we have quite a
lot and this was kind of unexpected at
the beginning at the beginning of this
so-called small key value stores we call
so we we have not much data maybe order
of from megabytes to a few gigabytes but
still you need to have global reputation
so to have low latency globally and they
have very very low or sometimes very
high ups this also doesn't map well so
summarizing this is the this is the
truth that we found during our migration
so there is a pretty big overlap between
Cassandra and BigTable for this low
consistency and high throughput
scenarios we have these two use cases
were that I call small value stores and
more consistent and I am fairly sure
that there is nothing in the blue part
of this graph so it's all one of these
three in cases basically at least is
poly fine it took a while to find out
this I suggest if you're doing a
migration like this try to figure out
these things beforehand I just don't say
oh yeah go and use BigTable and because
people is gonna come back to you and say
about yeah but we don't have these
features and doesn't work and for us was
also kind of funny because at the
beginning we had two features that were
very important for us they were missing
backups for which we built an internal
stopgap solution and global vacation
that now is available but at the time we
build a replicator customer theater
based on cloud pops up and I wrote this
like it was a potentially consistent
replicator because at some point we
found that basically he could you could
lose Sunday especially if I remember
correctly was something about ordering
off inserts and deletes yeah so it was
pretty funny that after two weeks away
yeah oh well cool those data yeah anyway
this is two fish are now are available
and yeah we use them a lot at least
sorry the glorification backups maybe
you're gonna get a question
and so now immigration is going slowly
we are I would say half away but yeah we
see that the number of victim knows is
increasing the number of Cassandra knows
is decreasing as a success story of
migration I would like to talk about the
playback cluster the basically
implements is very crucial for
implementing the connect feature if
you're familiar with that any stores
basically the device state so we have
multiple devices like TVs speakers and
you store the state of these devices the
state can be pretty big depending on how
the how the device works and it's very
it's sorry it's low consistency data is
I mean if you lose the state or you just
didn't generate a new one it's not a
super big deal and you need a very very
high performance because imagine like
you skip a song you go like that's a
change of the state sort and if you
count how many users so many devices
with there are is like hunts of
thousands of requests particularly had
we used to have on Cassandra 150,000 QPS
a peak in three data centers we used to
have 450 machines with 7,000 cores more
or less and 2.5 petabytes of SSD just
for this cluster and this was one of the
examples where I was saying like this
gossip was really pushed to the limit
like we could an add another 100 notes
to his cluster the the team managing
this cluster we used to have I believe
one incident today
during the last weeks of life and as a
fun fact or I would say what was
tragically bad about this cluster is
that we were using just very little of
the B's of the DS for the actual unique
data because we had to over-provision a
lot in terms of disk space - to handle
Cassandra compactions like you don't
want to run out of this space in a
center cluster and we have to work a
provision a lot to prevent that miss Kay
and the data is very ephemeral so yeah a
lot of compactions on BigTable II worked
out very well
we recently migrated like three four
months ago the team is very happy they
didn't have any operational headaches so
far we also scale this cluster in
between 150 250 nodes so we also have
less nodes and we pay for the data we
use so we have approximately 40
terabytes of unique data and yeah just
before that it was also nice because we
we work pretty closely with Google
engineers they were developing a new
client with Java client and yeah working
with the emulator is also cool so there
was a very nice experience and this is
like a chart of the the cost drop the
day we shut down the Cassandra machines
you can see the in green the compute e
compute engine cost
it doesn't goes down to zero because we
also have the service nodes in the in
the project but nevertheless is like
approximately 75 percent drop in cost
which is pretty big just few words on
how we did this migration it's an online
migration so we didn't say ok now the
feature is disabled for like few hours
and we swap maybe was always online what
we did is we implemented a storage
interface based on BigTable and we run
that together we can Sandra and of
course Cassandra was the primary
database for for this process and we
slowly send traffic to BigTable in order
to detect bugs to detect problems or
understand performance in general to
gain confidence that everything works
and by doing that you can also compare
like the data that you read from the
sound of the data that you read from
BigTable and see that everything makes
sense and yeah as I was saying the more
confidence you you get the more traffic
you in you can send to BigTable and
eventually you have hundred percent
rhythm right and when you when you feel
good you do the swap in between
Cassandra BigTable and eventually you
draw Cassandra so it's pretty simple
it's it's very simple because this candy
is ephemeral
so eventually basically your your your
two database converge the same data and
if you have few errors is fine in this
case or in cases like this and in cases
where you have persistent there so you
cannot tolerate errors like let's say
our playlist cluster it's much more
tricky at least with the Hasaan
diversion we have in generates three
wheels I mean keeping in sync to
distributed databases is not the best
but you there is a pretty difficult
point to solve around delete that even
if you sink often the the data from the
two database like the the lists are not
in the data export unless you do logical
delete if you don't do logical deletes
you need to change the schema which is
also very painful Google as a solution
for this which is based on newer
versions of a Cassandra which which we
don't use and yeah we're working around
this another thing we're working on is
trying to abstract let's say the
database layer so having
[Music]
like an interface that obstruct away
which database we are using like you may
interact with cloud span or cloud
BigTable like I stand a more or less in
the same way and there's something more
for the future so maybe if we have to do
this again it's gonna be much less
painful but we could also implement
pretty cool things like doing this dual
storage transparently for the user and
it's a pretty cool project and yet
hopefully we're gonna open source it if
he works said that during this process
we also develop an auto scalar which it
wouldn't be impossible because Sandra at
all because as I said changing the
number of nodes in a container closet
takes time especially big classic take
days
so we be table it's very very nice to
scale up and down in within minutes you
started as a hack project and it was
taken from bits and pieces of other
autoscaler we I think we had five out of
scalars at some point so we we have to
build one to rule them all so we call it
the amazing Victor's killer and it's
very simple set up it's a Java micro
service with a with some state kept in a
cloud sequel database basically the
logics more or less fetch the cluster
data the class of status every 30
seconds I believe in taking action or
not any token source before going more
into the details of the logic which is
very simple I just want to show what is
the effect of using the other scalar
normally so when you have constant
amount of resources in this case a
constant amount of nodes you would say
that the you have day and night and day
night cycles in CPU in Cassandra for
example that was that was the case
because you have more users during the
day less using during the night
using autoscaler you we see the opposite
so we can keep the CPU utilization
pretty much constant and changing the
resources over time I mean yeah these
are shows that this graph show that he
works pretty well and it works also for
replicated clusters because we do the
scaling at the cluster level not at the
instance server so we can get scaling
that independently different regions
basically and the logic as I was saying
is very simple so basically the user
defines target load and ghost killer so
given the given you have number of nodes
and it just tries to calculate and one
such the load is what the user defined
it just right arithmetic proportion
basically and then we have some some
checks some we want with respect some
properties so it's very simple state
machine for example we want to respect
the storage per node quota otherwise the
cluster stop receiving writes we want to
have n1 so the new number of nodes
should be in within the boundaries that
the user sets and also we don't want to
scale too frequently because one one is
because we have a certain amount of
admin operations so there is a folder on
administrations and but also we have
some latency spikes associated to
upscale so down scales which is also
something we are working to we Google to
solve yeah but as you see is a very
simple logic and for us worked really
well the only real problem we we found
is related to data jobs differ for jobs
in our case because they there are like
sudden spikes of load on the cluster and
the also scared cannot scale fast enough
so basically
and I think that the general
recommendation from Google is like if
you're doing a very heavy data flow job
you should upscale like 20 minutes
before and that's the solution
another solution could be to throttling
throttling the data flow jobs and it
sounds pretty crazy but it's fairly
doable if use a framework in in our case
we use a frame of CEO so we could
implement and CEO say yeah start slow
and slowly increase the rate in a way
that the autoscaler can cope with it
with that another solution could be to
use like a predictive so to transform in
a predictive process or integrate some
predictions like Facebook profit and
this would work if you have data for
jobs on a certain schedule not if you
have random during the day right now we
went with the second one because it was
the recommendation and it's like more or
less what we were already doing so yeah
and it works so far so yeah
wrapping up marriage is great we love it
where teams are very happy when moving
away from Cassandra we think for us is
the way forward because we want to yeah
free as much as overtime as possible is
not the migration is not an easy process
you still need to understand what like
you can't completely forget how things
works of course and I would say if there
is one key takeaway for us in our
storage infrastructure team is that you
need to make the process as easy as
possible for the user so like
documentation like Avenger evangelizing
good migrations like that the most you
can do or tooling also the most you can
do for them the better it is and yeah
auto scaling is a great example of value
that we can evangelize adding on top of
this and yeah the time and mostly the
time no I'm not even sure
how much money we're saving but the time
is the time savings are a big win
[Music]